last week a federal judge ruled that the
happy birthday song is now public domain
which I thought was cool yeah until this
ruling believe it or not you had to pay
thousands of dollars if you wanted to
sing the Happy Birthday song on TV
that's not a joke
you could not like for 22 years Italian
television sing other songs yes for 22
years I've been on TV and if it was
someone's birthday you could never sing
the Happy Birthday song because you had
to pay someone this a crazy amount of
money well now that it's free I thought
I would mark this historic milestone by
singing birthdays right now on the air
would that be cool let's do it is it
anybody's isn't anybody's birthday today
anybody's birthday at all
is it your it's your birthday it's
really your birthday this is so this is
so cool all right let's do this right
now that's the happy birthday that's so
exciting that's so exciting
cut what is uh what is your name
Cheryl well happy birthday Cheryl this
is so would you like me to sing you the
Happy Birthday song right now would you
like that all right I'm gonna do this is
historic I'm gonna sing the Happy
Birthday song two truck guys you help me
out here we go
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear Cheryl
happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
that was fun that was fun
didn't cost us a penny which is sweet
but to be fair Cheryl having a big
celebrity like me sing a song for you is
something people would pay a lot of
money for it
you seem nice so I'm only gonna ask for
$500 okay we take we take cash or I can
actually take a credit card if you've
got it yeah no credits fine credit fine
just me it's time on television and it's
not free you know that's great
hey and good news Cheryl for just
another hundred and twenty nine dollars
you'll be able to relive that special
birthday moment over and over again with
this commemorative VHS tape
and we're throwing in this Panasonic
forhead VCR recorder for a steal at $230
picture two you're gonna want pictures
to commemorate this event with your
friends and your families who are
throwing in at deluxe photo package for
a discounted price just three hundred
and fifty dollars
you're gonna want the keychain
you gotta get the keychain you got to
get the t-shirt sure and the
commemorative conan sings to you toilet
seat cover oh you know what the toilet
seat covered sister her card got
declined I probably ran up the price all
right yeah well why don't we do this
we'll get the money from you after the
show yeah thank you so much we got an
amazing program amazing show tonight
from the Fox series Brooklyn nine-nine
Terry Crews is here
from the BBC series Doctor Who Jenna
Coleman is a comedian Tom Clark was on
the side
so much more show coming up a ride back
Jimmy take it away wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]